[Music]
timmy i'm here what time is it it's 7 26
a.m
timmy i'm here call dr burns
i got her
what do you want for
[Music]
kimmy i'm here reopen my stream on
desktop i need more kitchen paper
open yesterday's stream
[Music]
i'm a voice stream interpreter i may
have heard a crime
on one of the streams the devices pick
up lots of things
just mark this degraded audio and delete
it i am not capable and you know it i
think a woman might need help
how do i find out who she is you need
the device number and the admin code
will you make me one this is the last
favorite question
closure files come to my office we'll
listen to the recordings together
miss childs i have to know what we're
dealing with we're dealing with what
sounds like a premeditated murder
how do i know that because i just told
you
twice now
maybe you've just replaced your real
stresses with this
can we please call the fbi
i understand that you have taken some
mental health leave in the past why is
that in my file
why don't you run you said you had it
they did
now they don't
kimmy bedtime legs
i'm here
the world waited for what felt like
forever
then
[Applause]
we waited longer
but this february
we promise it's gonna be the gnarliest
[ __ ] ever
the wait is over
hello i'm johnny knoxville welcome to
jackie
if you're gonna be dumb you gotta be
tough
when you get knocked down
if they trust us to go to the bathroom
they're less intelligent than i thought
i've been in the drawer but i know
enough
to know
if you're gonna be dumb you gotta be
tough you're still blowing people up as
if life's not hard enough this
francis hits harder than any heavyweight
in the mma i told aaron it was a
lightweight
that's not wait what are you talking
about
[Music]
we're together
what's the worst that could happen
[Music]
you said it wasn't gonna feel like
anything
i just need you to like sit with my
grandpa just make sure he doesn't smoke
[Music]
will you make him an actual coffee
stephanie
it's got to be over dude i think we're
all the way finished with through
stick a fork in it
[Music]
you don't even need to wear makeup
sorry what
i just said you don't even need to wear
makeup
all right
what was that
did you know anyone who died
don't
[Music]
did you have like the craziest
nightmares last night you have to be
able to sleep to have nightmares
tell me about your brother he was uh
always making me laugh
what are you feeling right now i feel
mad
you went through something no one should
ever have to go through
can you stay just fall asleep
i was [ __ ] hard i'm sorry we're
saying [ __ ] no you're right life's
[ __ ] hard god well try it it feels
good life's [ __ ] confusing
i can't [ __ ] feel anything
what are you thinking about i can't say
it let's say you die tomorrow and what
if you die sad because you regret not
saying what you want to say
[Music]
this can't be for
[Music]
the shoulders you can't do it without
the shoulders
[Music]
if you're watching this thing you know
by now a huge problem is heading our way
an emergency meeting is being called our
usual place immediately shrink bagels
i've made a shocking discovery
i need you to get me in touch with nasa
immediately well nasa and i aren't
really on speaking terms these days well
that'll change
when you tell them that the moon is out
of orbit
there's no need to panic knocks facing
why are they lying about all this
it's too late to stop
you knew all this was happening before
nasa
you're the unidentified source oh yes
we're dealing with an intelligent entity
we're planning a mission to attack this
thing
i'm asking you for your help
say yes brian
i need you to be brave
if the moon really is what you think it
is
suit up
you have got a big gravity weight coming
your way you have to launch now did he
say gravity wave
uh that's crazy
wait for it
[Music]
everybody hang on i'm gonna get you home
[Music]
it's on airplane mode
[Music]
farmer's daughter take one
i need to be famous wayne
all the best people are ain't nobody
else out there like you
you know why why
because you got that x factor
that days of struggling may soon be over
hollywood here we go
this is it our own studio background
i'm looking for a place to stay
oh yes sir
that's one of this home [ __ ]
and my wife pearl is next door so i
would appreciate a little discretion
you don't know what we're doing does he
well it's better to beg for forgiveness
and ask for permission
would you like to
come
inside much advice
i want to be in the movie well you can't
the story can't just change midway
through
if daddy catches us
there's no telling what he might do
my wife is not well
it happens after time
[Music]
you don't want to leave do you people's
eyes are going to pop out of their damn
skulls when they see this
what
are you all right
[Music]
one of the now found this inside what do
you think is on it
i see one goddamn [ __ ] up horror
picture
[Music]
they say these are crazy times
everyone out for themselves
and one day i got a chance to sell my
soul when i took it
[Music]
would you like to hear with me
you know what love is jack i've only
heard stories from a long time ago
you recently had any new type of
experience
like one
about the girl
why are they following me
the corporation won't stop until it has
you
your only chance is to stop seeing the
girl
what if i can't stay away from it
then
you will die
there isn't much time
in deteriorating quickly
these people are very dangerous
and you should walk away
[Music]
you ever been
scared of you
there were once two sisters
the older sister walked ahead of the
younger one
so the younger one always knew where to
go
how are you doing
because your graham and i have been a
little worried about you
my sister is dead
there's no more music in me
no more dreams in me
i've lost the one person on earth who
understood me
how is school bad as expected
he's a new boy in honor band
[Music]
hey
you must be lennon walker
toby stop by go keep him company make
him feel welcome he is not interested in
talking to me
she was the love of his
life one in school gets it
i don't think it's possible to get it
unless you're in it like we are um
you believe in science from the beyond i
believe in everything because you've got
me yes
by the way
the heart breaks
music escapes
that's how it gets out
if the tide takes california
[Music]
i'm so glad i got
i know i shouldn't have come i just
missed her so much
we're here
without her
[Music]
i don't think we get one without the
other
but joe i feel so very alive
but when i'm with toby there is someone
with me in my grief
i want to live like my sister did
with daring
and spirit
and so
much joy
[Music]
there's certain rules to surviving
[Music]
believe me i know
they always come back
the killer is a part of something in the
past
this one just feels different
[Music]
you're all in danger
i've seen this movie before
[Music]
not this movie
[Music]
go finish it sydney
[Music]
scream i'll be right back
he's dead only in theater in special
previews thursday at 7pm get tickets now
[Music]
larson i need you to come over to my
house and hook up with me every day
after school
what yeah you me sex stuff
how about a little back story while i
was setting the academic bar for our
generation my classmates were more
concerned with other things avery i'm
dtf
oh [ __ ]
we both know you don't do things you're
not great at god i can't be bad at this
this is not the time to be a
perfectionist i'm gonna blow you blow
whatever you're comfortable with
to master sexual excellence i'm going to
create an app that would collect data
and prescribe steps for a successful
sexual experience i should be collecting
data from my fellow students
there are certain partnered pleasure
approaches the rock and roll the surfs
up the double action revolver the spock
the reverse spot damn if you want to be
a dick sucking artist a penis picoxo a
bonee afrita cocklow
it's all about the tip
have you selected a practice partner yet
i can't sexualize you i respect you too
much for your brain for your
independence my god
i can't believe you just did that it's
fair play
technically it's foreplay don't be mad
on the confidence here we go godspeed
i think we can call today's experiment a
success
i have a hypothesis love leads to sex
and sex leads to love our dynamic needs
to remain strictly professional for the
sake of the experiment so if we're not
doing your experiment we can't hang
you kids are overly worried about
getting good at the sex stuff it's a
relationship that takes practice
[Music]
you just launched a harpoon without
tying the rope off i'll tie it off i i
have several ropes ribbed ropes
pre-lubed ropes
reel it in skipper
you gotta try things to know what you
want there's a diversity of options
you've got your lefties your righties
your straight shooters your curvatures
i'll just be at hometown buffet sampling
the local beef
[Music]
[Music]
don't you think your mom would want you
to be happy
come be in the picture with that
happy
but how
[Music]
welcome
to the world of you
you may not be able to start over in the
real world
but you can start over
in the world of you
with its unique body sharing technology
you was able to draw out a user's hidden
strength
i could finally sing again
she made it unused global music charts
just as i expected i'm so sad
nobody in their right mind would ever
have that bell's user is actually a
mousy nobody like you i guess it's true
that everyone's hiding some kind of
secret
susie something wrong
why are you still here wait who is that
a dragon this is typical internet
behavior why does he do stuff that'll
make people hate him
preserve the peace in you this creature
must be disposed of
who are you really
he's in danger what wait
i have to help him
oh girls you're singing
but i don't know what to
how are we do to find one person out of
five billion accounts
actually there's something i've been
meaning to ask you for quite a long time
now
when the truth is revealed what do you
want to bet no one will pay any
attention to a single one of your songs
[Music]
sing
where's the front door
just tell me yeah right there straight
ahead okay so i'll make it quick because
i'm late for my flight the security
system's just down the hall the guest
room's all ready for you ciao
have a safe play
see for me connect to a sighted helper
on demand for visual assistance in a
live video call
high ceilings fireplace and floor to
ceiling windows with a great view
thank you
[Music]
system disarmed
hey quiet
we've got a problem i think someone's
here
see for me
hey how can i help you there's people in
the house are you sure yeah i think
they're looking for me
[Music]
[Music]
we need to offer right now she's seen
our faces no i have it
what's going on here
where's the girl
please listen to me
they're gonna kill you
what should i do
oh what a mistake baby
kelly
this work is incredible well that's my
favorite part about taking photos you
wander and find places like this it
makes me a little delirious i like what
your eyes are doing to me right now
that's really cheesy no it was um a
little cheesy um maybe i'll see you here
again sometime
you said he was cute
emojis are cute that guy is melting my
sunglasses tess
i think you could sell this stuff but
there is something that's missing from
like all of your photos you
i love you jose
welcome back to the world of the
living too much
i just wish i could see him one more
time even for a minute
he loved him and he knew that
[Music]
[Music]
what is happening when the separation is
dramatic there's unfinished business
he's in the in between
he's reaching out to you
reach back your ghost hunting assistant
has arrived a ouija board
oh my god
sorry that was me
if you do manage to cross there may be
no way back
here
i'm gonna find him
[Music]
i'm still here with this
[Music]
by the pricking of my thumbs
something wicked this way comes
my husband
king that shall
be we should fail
we fail
[Music]
does that not hear noise
he thought i heard a voice cry sleep no
more
[Music]
[Music]
the devil
i have no words my voice is in my sword
it's time for us to move out and make
our mark on the world awesome
oh no
those ding-dongs went back to the lost
world oh and i thought i made bad
choices
the lost world
the world's most dangerous place
wait a minute can you repeat that i had
a marshmallow in my ear oh [ __ ] crying
out now
what brings you to here
we came here to live a life of adventure
like you
i'm starting to question our judgment
this is the perfect time to do it
it's time to get back wild [ __ ] you like
a superhero
i wouldn't use the term superhero
i mean i wouldn't stop you from using it
ah i love family reunions
[Music]
ah
[Music]